يتهم روسيا باستهداف بنيه تحتيه اجتماعيه
وحيويه صباح الخير نعم
هذه قصه ممتده لنا للاسف الكبير وكنا
نتوقع ان الروس سيكرر
تكتيكاته في من في الشتاء الماضي حيث
حاولوا تدمير البنيه التحتيه الخاصه
بالطاقه قبل كل شيء والان يحاول
فعل ذلك
ولكن الصوره تختلف بسبب ان الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه اصبحت قويه جدا مقارنه
بالنه
الماضيه
ولذلك يكثفون ضرباتهم بكل وسائل بطائرات
بدون طيار وصواريخ مجنحه وصواريخ
بالست يتم اطلاقها من السفن ونحن ن نعلم
ان
الاسطول البحر الاسود
هو يعني اززي تقريبا ولكن مع ذلك يكثفون
جهودهم في ح الاتجاه
و قد مضى جزء كبير من الشتاء وهم لم
ينجحوا حتى
الان في تدمير البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
ويحاولون في في الانتاج يعني تحقيق ذلك و
كما نرى النتائج هناك
عده
اشخاص قتلوا
وجروا يعني واصب
بجخ
ولاحقه اضرار
بمباني سكنيه وغير سكنيه و كراجات
مستودعات ونحو ذلك وب مستشفى الولاده
ايضا اظن ان هذه الاهداف ان روس استهدفوا
هذه الاهداف بالضبط هذا يعني ان معظم تلك
الصواريخ التي اطلقوها تم اسقاطهم
و تساقط الشظايا
والختام يسبب هذه الاضرار ولكن هذا ليس
ما خطط له الروس اشكرك سيد ميكولا باستن
استاذ مساعد في جامعه اللغات في كيف على
هذه المداخله